[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm link and I'm
red this week at the round table of dim
lighting we have Lilly Singh known to
her fans on YouTube as superwoman
superwoman is a comedic vlogger with
millions of subscribers subscribers a
unique background an empowering voice
and a hilarious impersonation of her
parents we discussed with her
involvement in the religion of Sikhism
how YouTube made her lose her religion
and why she needs a security team when
she meets fans and her parents homeland
of India also we did something that
maybe we shouldn't do at least we did it
for the first time and that is we gave
her our input our advice on her love
life well so we'll see my advice is
better see how she takes that we'll get
into that in a second but first i I've
been holding this story read I didn't
want to tell you what happened to me
my airport experience I wanted to share
it with all of you out there and with
read at the same time so yeah I just
don't like I don't like for you to hear
a story and then have to act like you're
hearing it again so this is but I am
very good at that
I'm saving I've saved this one for all
of you together have you ever seen an
angel mmm I've seen paintings
have you ever important in real life
yeah some people think they have or
maybe they have other people maybe have
been angels have you ever been an angel
I don't know that this it works that
that's the intro to my story for you I
believe that in some way I've been I've
been an angel is it that a song there's
at country country band Alabama has the
song I believe there are angels among us
oh and that is kind of what I'm thinking
about Oh
believe there are angels among us I was
one of those angels to somebody okay
here's what happened okay I'm my
interest is piqued I flew to Google
headquarters for a panel to discuss what
we do but things are so busy that we
decided that Rhett was gonna stay back
and work on some other stuff kind of
divide and conquer so to speak and I am
just not in the habit of checking flight
information ahead of time I don't I just
assume everything's gonna work out just
fine or that they'll text me or
something so I get to Burbank Airport to
fly to San Francisco I'm flying back the
same night it's just the first time I've
ever done that I felt like a businessman
getting on a plane for a meeting they
get right back on a plane come back to
and fro in the same day yeah I get to
Burbank and I get up to the the ticket
counter and of course nobody's there at
Burbank there's no lines that's the
beauty of flying out of Burbank and get
up there I was okay 10:30 flight to San
Francisco sir it's been canceled
okay it's not not delayed ain't even
happening do they say you got to fly
there with your angel's wings no I said
well I mean I got a I've got to
basically be there in a couple hours and
then I'm flying back there's no way this
can happen what can you do they said
well there is there's no other flight
out of here can you get to LAX which is
at that time of day at least an hour
drive to drive all the way across LA to
get to LAX huge airport then you got all
those problems right well yeah I mean if
you could do that so she booked me on a
flight out of LAX and I'm gonna get back
in the car and just drive there I said
well you got to change in my return
flight because I'm flying back tonight
and I'm gonna get back in my car and
drive back so she's I don't think I can
do that but then she was able to work
her magic and do both of those things
potential angel candidate okay about the
time that I'm wrapping up an old lady
kind of walks up almost hobbles up I'm
just gonna be honest to the kiosk next
to me she says 10:30 flight to San
Francisco who I'm sorry that flights
been canceled immediate physical bodily
reaction from this woman I thought she
was going to start crying oh no I I have
to meet my daughter she said well
there's a 3:30 flight I cannot wait that
late she wasn't being
clear a jerk but she was distraught but
she was legitimately upset what was the
engagement well I don't know she's
talking to the moment at the kiosk and
the woman at the kiosk said well that's
the best we can do I mean I can book you
out of LAX say well how would I get to
LAX and I look at her I said this angel
right here you can ride with me
and I just it is just one of those
moments where I didn't even really think
I was just like that wow we're in the
same situation she needs to go to the
same place she's upset she's an old lady
and you know that you know the saying
helping old lady across the street what
about helping old lady across a los
angeles is even better and she's more
work so I said I can take you and she
turns and looks at me looks me up and
down thanks for a second and she says
well I'll take that risk
that's what she's yeah yeah so I'll take
that risk and I was like okay you just
did it you looked at me and just did a
risk assessment and she kind of laughed
and the the two girls behind the kiosks
started laughing and she said you you
look like a fine young man
okay I was like I was like I got to go
to the bathroom I'll meet you right back
here in a few minutes and then we can
get in my car you're really gonna drive
so the lighten the load added an extra
passenger so I went to the restroom and
then I came back and I just had this
feeling of like I don't know maybe like
I was did how I'm do all of a sudden I'm
in the middle of doing a good deed
are you this makes me feel amazing do
you do good deeds so seldomly that they
I guess it just gave you a feeling of
exhilaration and then we're walking out
to the old lady to the airport no you
did not I'm like taking her luggage for
like we're going we're having to go up
the parking deck and she gets in the car
she's talking to her daughter on the
phone and she's like well it's this this
fine young man nice young man has
decided he's going to take me across Los
Angeles and I'm still gonna be there I
don't know what time but I think I'm
gonna make it and at that point we're
already
driving she's on the phone with her
daughter and I'm thinking yeah you
should you should tell her that I I'm
also gonna chop you up and eat you for
dinner like that's the that's the joke
that went through my mind you kept that
to yourself a cannibalistic serial
killer Jeff you you should have kept
that to yourself right now your biscuits
why I thought that I guess because I was
surprised that she would just ride with
a total stranger out of luck Ross lost a
man who needs to get to San Francisco I
mean how bad can you be well I could be
a serial killer
I mean serial killers don't take flights
like that you know I I just don't I
don't believe that
so you're an angel think the joke that I
thought serial killers plan out things
over months they don't just like say I'm
gonna go the airport maybe my flight ago
he can't get cancelled and I'll take
somebody to they know they there's
totally circumstantial there she has no
reason to be suspicious other than the
way you look well I appreciate
everything that the last thing you said
because I I am torn between thinking I'm
a potential serial killer or like an
like an angel in disguise so you know we
had a we had a lovely hour-long
conversation too though what was what
was so I was visiting her daughter her
husband had recently passed away so she
wanted to spend some time with a
daughter like RNR I don't know why she
was in such a hurry to get there oh well
it would have been better if I said she
had to get to like a wedding no she
didn't
I'm sorry the birds I have to be honest
but we had a lovely hour-long
conversation and it's just funny because
I you know when we get there I want to I
want to pay for valet and you know I
don't think there's valet parking at LAX
and it turns out there wasn't but she
still gave me a $50 bill Wow
and I was the glad at that point that I
didn't say that the serial killer joke
out loud because I got the $50 helped
her helped her check her bag and get in
there we're on the same flight and she
made it and and then you know I got home
told my wife and I got some brownie
points if you know what I mean from the
wife for a B and you know so I'm not
telling you people in order to
any sort of Wow
I'm just seeing how your credit I feel
like I feel like I know you well but
okay I see how it works how it works in
your lien when you do a good deed you
surprise yourself you have thoughts of
what it would be like if I was a serial
killer in this ensign yeah instance and
then your wife gives you favors when you
do this is I need to be rewarded for
this you need to be better
self-motivated to think is the answer
here it felt good to be an angel I think
I'd like to do it one day okay
all right full time angel it's called
John Travolta
I recommend that okay well you did
something good and you know I think it's
appropriate that you did one good thing
this week because our guest this week on
air biscuits is very much about doing
good that's kind of her that's kind of
her message a Lilly superwoman scene
she's garnered over two million subs and
176 million views in the past three
years thanks to her comedic vlogs a
couple of examples how girls get ready
has four and a half million views and
types of kids at school has 4.4 million
so here's our conversation with the
angelic question mark this is super the
superwoman superwoman
[Music]
yeah just keep you know whenever you
move just keep the microwave are you
gotcha
just to keep it right there yes sir you
can't hear yourself we can't hear you
kind of looking in a camera if you can't
if you can't see the camera the camera
can't see you I have to tell that to
adults all the time and group pictures
you think an adult would know that now
I don't think adults know how to take
pictures or am I just referring to
Indians right maybe just in his will
tell us more about that Indians can take
pictures it's as simple as that my mom
tries taking pictures of me with my cell
phone
true story once went to India I went to
every historical place my mom took a
picture of me every place and I came
home with an empty memory guard hundred
percent true story what I guess
in Indian parents do not understand the
concept of you have to push the button
down a little bit and then push it down
all the way so it's just she pushed it
down a little bit each time and no
picture got she's focused off I focused
a whole lot and no memories were
captured
she story that's kind of sad because I
mean was that a big trip uh yeah it's
last time on to India suppose like nine
years ago and that scarred me and I've
never gone back except I'm going back
next month to take all the pictures
again right you're gonna go all recreate
all those scenes gonna get the diarrhea
gonna relive all the memories oh you had
diarrhea everyone gets a rule and you
were asking your mom to take photos of
it that's the only thing I wanted photos
focus much don't know spoke exactly
focus I'm so focused right now but it's
it's interesting because when you take
pictures it kind of helps to solidify
memories so in the absence of those
pictures do you feel like you're
starting to question whether it even
happened a percent if I get fuzzy if I
don't take a picture of my cheesecake I
feel like I've never eaten the
cheesecake on Instagram that's my issue
like it validates that I ate that
cheesecake and if I don't have a picture
of that cheesecake I never ate it and I
feel that this is a symptom of culture
seriously we're dependent upon pictures
to supplement our memory and that's why
I only take family pictures with
snapchat I just you know I just I take
pictures of myself with snapchat of
course snapchat for you know in all
family pictures in all promotional
pictures it's all snapchat and just
lives for a little bit and because I
want my memory to hold it I don't want
my MacBook to hold it for my interesting
I'm not like that at all my Instagram
holds everything well what happens when
the grid goes down Lily then I stop
living life and that's pretty much it I
don't even know how existed before
Instagram to be honest the only reason I
do things these days is because of
Instagram and it's sad but it's true the
other day I got courtside seats to a
basketball game I don't know a thing
about basketball nothing about
basketball my first thought is like holy
crap is gonna be an awesome Instagram
picture like that was my first and
probably only thought thinking what did
you snap I took a picture of one time
the basketball hit my leg I took a
picture of that I took a picture of my
tickets I took a
picture of will net ball hit your leg
you were actually poised to take no you
know it was it was rolling slowly and so
I kind of took my camera and I was
prepped for one that ball hit my life
this is an NBA basketball yes so and
this was when like Kobe Bryant was
having a conversation with us and I was
like can you just stop speaking so I can
take a picture right exactly stop being
rude Kobe God oh well she's trying I
went to India basketball game but I was
in the upper deck how did she get
courtside seats this is um this was a
meeting I actually also came late and
got there at halftime so that seat was
empty
true story actually in Drake's seats so
that's how ungrateful I am but um it was
a business meeting for a movie that
someone wanted to be me to be in and
they're like hey let's have a meeting uh
come to the basketball game so a cool
let's have a meeting courtside and I
came in those court snot-nosed all crap
I came late and I'm one of those
douchebags I came late well I got a
picture of my knee I was a power play as
a power play
so how long have you been on YouTube I
my first video was three years ago that
absolutely sucked it was mostly because
I bought a new blazer and I want to show
it off so I made a youtube video but I
jacket blazer like a car like like a
Chevy Blazer oh god no it was
legitimately just a blazer from RW & Co
which I don't know if you have that
store here no think we did it's a fancy
store it was a fancy it was $70 I was
like Frick I'm showing this off so
that's why I'm in Quenya know it was
just gray but it was like sophisticated
it was a fitted sophisticated blazer so
that's why I made the video but it was a
vlog about the Blazer no it was a spoken
word piece about religion it's so like
nothing I've ever done before the spoke
I really standing there with a piece of
paper talking about something and that
was my video so you just your motivation
to make the video as I look good in this
blazer but I've got to talk about
something yes I don't know yes and no my
motivation to make it a video was the
blazer the message though I was like
should I do an audio shouldn't because
the record is broken were just like you
know what so the video factor was
decided by the blazer but the actual
message was because I was a little bit
of a different person when starting
youtube I was very religious and I was
very about that and
to be honest though YouTube's kind of
change that for me a little bit and I'm
not that person anymore so which is why
that videos not up anymore
I was about to say I you know we just
went and tried to find that first video
we're not trying to find that one just
saw what your first video was it was not
that way so you took it down yep
now what's what's the religion so the
religion is Sikhism okay which you could
say Sikhism depending on where you're
from but well if you say Sikhism is okay
that's what we're gonna say right cuz
usually when I say um I have to say that
isn't part one is a six iron fan emus
that are like wait what's wrong with you
your sex up ya know thing happens but
it's Sikhism Sikhism which is a religion
from northern part of India mostly
Punjab uh-huh I'm trying to say facts I
really don't know anything yeah so this
is and this is a minority religion in in
India right there's a fairly new
religion as well worldwide newer
religion as in how new I don't know I'm
gonna say a couple hundred years okay
yeah so pretty young religion what are
the basic basics of this religion are so
one God doesn't matter what religion you
follow whether you follow goddesses gods
they believe in just one overall being
that's imageless and they don't believe
in rituals they believe in they don't
believe in which is what they believe in
certain things to follow so it's a
little bit confusing i don't know
everything about it but so
characteristic traits would be wearing a
turban not cutting your hair stuff like
that i'm monotheistic religion in india
where there's hinduism which is
obviously not that right very
polytheistic so how is how's it
different when people when people meet
you and they okay she's from an Indian
background do they just assume things
about your religious they assume a
vegetarian but I am which is kind of not
helping my case vegetarian my parents
are super strict I'm not allowed to
drink a fun party do my eyebrows shaved
my legs
uh-huh things like that I get a lot of
that and that's obviously not true about
it is it depends how religious
you are and what you think about
religion why I discovered that religion
is just not for me it's because everyone
interprets at their own way and having
said that everyone interprets at their
own way but then also judges people in
their own way so really I feel like
religion is just whatever you want it to
be and people forget that sometimes I'm
very curious that you said that as you
became a youtuber and developed this
career that you have now that that
seemed to be the driving force and kind
of moving away from I guess what was
your religious upbringing so I like to
put a pin in that I like to come back to
that but let's let's go back to the
beginning of your each of your story
here not even not even YouTube I'm
talking about where were you born where
were you raised what was that like so I
was born and raised in Scarborough which
is a pretty ghetto little suburb in
India and Kannada so I was born and
raised there I went to a ghetto school
which explains a lot of my get honest
and my videos and I liked love to
embrace that so when people find ghetto
ghetto is like my neighborhood had a lot
of like when the ice cream truck came
around it was like the excitement of the
weekend and if he wasn't jumped and
robbed it was even better so you're
saying it was like a poor neighborhood
or it was dangerous neighborhood I have
like my school the area of my school
isn't had a lot of crime a lot of
violence it was like we were never
allowed to do anything in school never
allowed to hold events never allowed to
have school trips because it was
considered this dangerous area with a
lot of crime and gangs and just it was
that area I was always on the news it
was kind of that you know the media made
it into that area that was like don't go
there you're gonna get jumped or shot or
something so so did your parents move
from India - yep so - I have that
typical story of arranged marriage so my
parents had an arranged marriage my dad
came to kind of first sponsored my mom
over and then they had my sister and I
and what what brought your parents over
the same thing that brings everything
together I was just like oh the dream
and the dream of getting a job and just
better opportunities and so what line of
work was he in or is he my dad when he
first came to India had like three jobs
he was a furniture he said came to India
it's hard came to Canada he was a
furniture salesman he was a security
guard
my mom worked at a factory currently my
parents run a line of gas stations so
they have a chain of gas stations that
they manage okay and so their marriage
was arranged and were they in the Sikh
Sikh religion as well so that's why you
were brought up that way oh yeah when
you are in an arranged marriage you have
no options like that it's like you have
to be the same religion from the same
village and went to the same school and
Beyond the from the same side of this
river it's very particular of who you
have to marry so what age did they get
married oh I think my mom was young
she's probably like valid questions
probably 20 okay which is pretty old for
something 16 so so what was that like
five years younger than you
yeah what was that this age my mom had
two kids so what was it like growing up
in a household where you know your
parents are an arranged marriage uh-huh
yeah there's a lot of built-up you know
when I was your age I never got to do
that never got to Dana never had any
choices and so it's like because I
struggled and went through this your
life also has to be held because of that
so to be honest though my parents are
super cool like my mom's I think kind of
given up on me in a way as well so I
don't think that's ever gonna happen to
me they'll never force me to get an
arranged marriage and my parents to be
honest when I was growing up back to the
whole religious thing I was way more
religious than my parents my parents
were never really super religious to
begin with how did that happen I don't
know I feel like it's just something I
connected with growing up I went to the
temple way more than my parents they
never really taught me anything about
citizen be honest everything I learned
on my own and it's just something I
really connected with for a certain
amount of time and what's the age
difference with your sister six years
she's older older she's older she's that
normal sibling that's married and has
kids and very normal so she wasn't
really into not at all no no one from my
family with the exception of my
grandfather but he was even in India
when I was growing up so I really have
no idea how I went down that path no
idea and then so how devout were you
what are some clear there was a period
of time when I used to go the temple
every day I just loved I used to go
every day I used to be listening to
religious like hymns every day and I
just I don't know it was like for a year
or two three the first time I became
vegetarian my life was religious reasons
now a vegetarian has nothing to do with
religion so so the the Sikh religion
vegetarianism its interpretation some
people say it doesn't say and you were
in there you're vegetarians some people
like no of course page 54 of this this
is vegetarian so it's really if you're a
baptized sick then I believe you do have
to be vegetarian again I could be
totally making that up so don't bombard
my facebook with religious texts right
now so just like Christianity there is a
baptism yes yes yes so imagine it's a
different BAP yeah it's a it's the same
kind of process same kind of rebirth has
the holy water you're getting kind of
reborn into this new light same kind of
concept so what was it like you know
obviously your parents come from one
culture and then they come to the West
and things are very different for them
but they're basically who they're going
going to be you're born here so you're
born in the West but you kind of
gravitate towards this this religion
which represents your culture but at the
same time you're going to this ghetto
school you say right so what was
happening confusion was happening in my
school I was a really big minority as
well in terms of culture I was one of
like 10 punjabi people in my school so I
didn't have a lot of issues sometimes
with racism which is weird because the
other kids were also brown with just a
different type of brown and I think that
might have been one of the reasons why I
started to identify with my religion and
cultures because I didn't see it at my
school so I was like I want to learn
more about it and identify and figure
out who I am and that's probably one of
the factors that led me towards it but
yeah so there's a lot of confusion were
you shunning some of those Western
things that maybe now you're embracing
more oh not at all to be honest I was
still very open-minded about pretty much
everything the thing about growing up in
my family is like I said it wasn't
religious but still very cultural two
very different things
religion and culture clashed severely
there's things in the Indian culture
that are very very super sexist and
super elitist and super everything that
are nowhere in religion so it's really
that's one of the reasons why I've
gravitated away from religion because
culture and religion clash too much and
I believe it's all hypocritical but I
thought you were saying that it was the
the cultural
things that were added on to the
religion that created the sexism but
you're saying that it's more the
religious beliefs I'm saying I'm saying
inevitably people over time connect
culture and religion when they shouldn't
be connected so you'll have people who
follow a holy script that's all about
equality and all of this but those same
religious people will be like but my
daughter can't do this and my son can so
those two become intertwined that's the
biggest problem I feel with religion
okay so if you were the devout when I
mean your parents were saying things
like you've got it so much better than I
do but you were saying what but I'm
denying myself certain things or I'm
going I'm more religious than you right
so were you imposing more rural keeping
on yourself so your parents didn't have
to do that or what was the relationship
there it was really just kind of a
non-existent one to be honest it wasn't
even like I imposed my religious beliefs
on my family they did to me they're like
oh she's going to the temple great
should all the house goddamn this is
beautiful for us it wasn't even like I
connected the tune anyway
my parents obviously weren't opposed to
me going to the temple they don't really
care it was just a little bit
indifferent to them I always had that
choice it was never like nilly you have
to follow these beliefs and you have to
do this even right now as a
non-religious person my parents will
never be like you need to say you're
sick and you need to follow this you
need to go up the temple never they'll
never do that but were they having
issues with some of the other cultural
things that you're experiencing 100%
culturally my parents hate me you know
what kind of things were you doing that
they started from when I started doing
YouTube videos and even growing up I
used to dance I used to be professional
funginner dancer and hit like a hip-hop
dancer I make youtube videos right now
and I'm put myself in the Internet
culturally coming from an Indian
background my parents hated that when I
first started dancing I was literally
told like you cannot dance cuz you're a
woman and it looks really bad and people
will judge you for that you can't make
youtube videos because the who which
family is gonna want to marry like this
woman who makes these YouTube videos
there's so many things like that you as
a child how did they when you started
showing interest and started doing these
things and they may have disapproved of
how they enforce that well how did they
try to enforce it when I started dancing
I mom literally said no she tried to
make it so I couldn't she's like you are
not allowed to go do it and it was
literally me going I'm going to do it
and just a huge fight and just getting
her to understand
eventually but even now sometimes
there's things were if I was to bring
home someone that I wanted to marry one
day that wasn't the same religion and
culture that would be an issue that
would be a battle in itself so there's
things like that there's a whole bunch
of my parents are super cool my mom
knows all the lyrics to Drake but at the
end of the day she stole an Indian
mother and she has lots of cultural
cultural things she believes in that I'm
just like mom no maybe she should do it
like a lip sync video or something might
go viral
she probably she knows every lyric to
drink just every lurch every surface
every song on the radio she's so cool
she's super suit if you don't put it on
your channel we'll put it on ours give
her her own channel that's frustrating
because she's so cool in so many ways so
leaning now she loves YouTube things
she's just so cool but then there's
certain things that are embedded into
them that they cannot change now you
mentioned your mom yeah how was your dad
responding to these things oh my I can
literally say my dad is my number one
fan legitimately number-one fan he knows
how many subscribers I have at any given
moment if you ask him he'll know the
exact number of subscribers I have he
knows how many views any of my videos
have he knows which collaborations that
cutestory he knows what I tweet he
doesn't even have Twitter he doesn't
know twitter is you know how he figures
it out he goes to my video goes to the
description clicks the link to Twitter
and then reads my tweets because he
doesn't understand that you can just go
Twitter calm so he goes through that
whole process to check my tweets now
it's funny because when you're talking
about your dad and your mom I've
realized that I am picturing you my
characters because you do a lot of that
I mean one of the first things that Rena
both said when we were watching your
videos in prep was happyslip just really
you know how you reminded us of her just
the way that she would play characters
and I guess you know she's not a white
girl maybe it's just kind of a
supportive racism thing that we're but
how she would play all those she and
influence um I feel like in terms of the
characters one of the biggest influences
would be jenna Marbles sure I feel like
she does a lot of characters also
growing up in the YouTube community
she's white though she is white you
influenced by
you'll like I don't always judge people
by the color of their skin just
sometimes and growing up there's also
these two youtubers in Toronto who are
males and there are Indian um and there
are big influence for me as well
who's that so they're just rain in a que
there
I hope you've probably never heard of
them maybe unfortunately they're just
there during one on the Toronto
community and probably and in the rest
of Canada and India obviously but they
influenced me a lot because they did a
lot of the characters and a lot of the
which is I will always admit because
people always pinned me against them and
if they're listening does anyone listen
to this will populate all right know how
the teenyboppers because in Toronto we
are kind of those three Brown YouTube
kids and everyone pins us against each
other so when I say like yeah I got
inspired by them it's usually a huge
huge deal because people compare you and
they try to and I just don't care for
that so yeah John Dubrow said I've
gained a lot of inspiration from them
yeah and I think you know like lately
link said we're picturing you playing
the characters of your parents and
that's something that you know you're
pulling on that cultural heritage and
your the way that your parents
perspective and you're finding comedy in
that the people are really connecting
with like how did you make that choice
that okay I'm going to you know I'm not
gonna be ashamed of my background I'm
gonna kind of leverage my background and
my culture cultural heritage to kind of
you know creep my content I feel like
there's two things I go into that one is
I want to show people how no matter that
my parents are Indian or whatever
they're probably exactly like your
parents and that's an underlying message
in all my videos and why I started
showing my parents even more or the most
cultural kind of stereotypes even more
because I love in the comments of people
like my parents are this they're Asian
they're black they're white they're but
they're just as crazy as that and so the
first time I showed those kind of
cultural stereotypes was because I
didn't know anything else that's what I
want to show because that's what happens
at home and that when I started to see
that everyone connects with that I'm
like this is no longer me showing my
Indian parents as me showing my parents
that everyone else connects to right
that was kind of like a very deep
spiritual thing I went through one of
the very one of the many lessons YouTube
has taught me is just that everyone is
different everyone is the same so when
you started making your YouTube
videos let's go there so went from dance
to and you won that battle huh at what
point did the YouTube videos come into
the equation so I danced all through my
at the end of high school and all
through my university life I never did
youtube in school while I was still in
university which I feel is a blessing
because I feel like I would totally just
dropped out um so I got my degree and it
was in between deciding whether I want
to do my masters or get a nine-to-five
that I decide to make youtube videos it
was literally like it was your undergrad
degree in it was psychology so I was
debating doing my masters in counseling
psychology and I remember doing the
applications and I was like I freaking
hate this I don't want to do this at all
so I literally went into my parents room
I was like listen I don't want to do my
masters I want to make youtube videos
and my after the ambulance came and left
and all that jazz from my parents heart
attack I'll never forget my dad was like
listen you want to make youtube videos
just do it the best do it better than
everyone else do to the best of your
ability and just rock it I'm since then
I've been attempting to rock it cuz I'm
like damn my parents are only gonna be
cool this was so long I need to become a
superstar or this is not gonna work no
that's interesting it's interesting way
to see it you know especially thinking
about like our story of the way that we
got into YouTube at a time where it was
no-one was thinking about it no one knew
that it could be a career it was just
like a place to put videos and then
everybody kind of started realizing it
but you came to kind of a crossroads in
terms of your career and one of your
options was YouTube so how did you what
had happened before that to give you
that perspective that YouTube could be a
career that point in time had a few
videos are and I mean like they were
hitting one of my videos like 40,000
views around that kind of range and at
that point I had done my research like I
was a big fan of Jenna at that time I
was a big fan of Ryan big fan of Epic
Meal Time and after doing that research
I didn't think that YouTube's gonna be
my career even right now I don't think
YouTube is gonna be that career I want
to entertainment to be my career but I
thought you two would be a platform for
that so at that point in time I had done
my research
and I think I even had met up with
Harley Harley was one of my big
inspirations in the sense that I was a
little small youtuber and I made a video
once that kind of mentioned Epic Meal
Time and he followed me on Twitter and I
remember fangirling so hard he came to
Toronto and I do
I'm saying hey do you want to like just
meet up and I had the most inspirational
memorable conversation with a guy he's
so friggin intelligent and so you have a
date with Harley not a I wish I could
say it was a date but my manager and my
other friend were there cock-blocking
the whole situation no it was literally
just I was like I really would love to
meet you and just like talk to you too
because I don't know much about it so he
was so kind
he literally met up with me in just the
lobby of his hotel we had a drink and
just the best conversation ever
and from that I remember being like holy
crap I'm inspired and this is totally
possible he was talking about his merch
tongue we're always conferences
conventions by deserts full time just
the whole business aspect of it that
I've never seen before I was like you're
more than a beard and bacon I don't get
it did he use the cheese analogy no okay
he did that on it when he was here this
table it was it was inspirational
I feel like everyone should have a
conversation with Harley I think he's
one of the most inspirational people
ever met maybe he could be a counselor
which seems yeah ironic a Jewish camp
several which means his camp experience
okay so you so what was when you made
that decision to just put YouTube videos
up before that before that decision to
go for it you know leading up to the
40,000 views here at 40,000 views there
what was the what was the initial
motivation I know you said okay I've got
this this new suit new new blazer I'm
gonna make a video were you a part of
the like an observer of the YouTube
community at the time not really not
really at all I think I keep became more
of an observer of the YouTube community
when I got involved in the YouTube
community and even right now there's a
lot of youtubers that I should know that
I know nothing about it was more so ever
since a young age I just loved
entertainment I used to dance as I
mentioned I love I think I even used to
make little silly videos with my
cousin's when I was growing up and I
could just never imagine myself having a
95 job even today like I could never
ever imagine having a 95 job working for
someone I was doing anything that's not
just absolutely weird silly and fun I
could never do it so it just kind of
fell into place I was like there's this
thing YouTube and when I was growing up
in high school there was no YouTube
we've got no idea what YouTube was and
it was like a self-discovery where I saw
a video and I was like oh my god what is
this thing and solely I was like YouTube
I want to do this and
this got into it so you were studying
Jenna and Harley and other people and
then what was your application just to
really start making it a career to kind
of go for it I can honestly say if my
first couple of videos hadn't been
received so well I might have never made
another one I was blessed in the sense
that I really hit a niche market where
this brown girl came on YouTube I was
outspoken and I was like what and so I
feel because of that was received so
well because there's no other well I
hope I'm not making this up I can't
think of another Indian female youtuber
does what I do so I really hit that
market where people will start sharing
and they're like this is like nothing
I've seen before and that happened when
I started making my first comedy videos
it was after I took that first video
down and I tried comedy it was received
super super well right yeah so I mean
you know you intern you mention an
interesting thing there that one of the
things that sets you apart that you're a
brown girl who is stepping up and
speaking in this way that maybe she
wasn't scared to say brown girl
culturally there maybe this whole
cultural heritage there that is saying
you shouldn't be talking like this you
shouldn't be portraying women in this
way or whatever they might say so do you
kind of feel like a rebel I would love
to feel like that I do feel like that I
think being the whole brown girl has its
pros and cons one huge con is that no
matter what I do I will be hey that
Brown youtuber who will always be
classified as that Brown YouTube will
always be clumped with the other Brown
youtubers and that's what she does
that's like the defining trait is a big
Pro because I'm gonna be completely
honest if I wasn't that brown girl and I
was just that girl there's many those
girls on YouTube so I don't think I
would have gained that traction in the
beginning that I did if I wasn't that
Brown girl
so you mean did you observe that the
audience was kind of insulated in its
and it started in that community under
precisely even majority of right now of
my fan base is still brown and that's
inevitable and I feel like that's okay
because um I feel like that's like I
said inevitable and I'm not one of those
people it's like no I don't wanna I
don't want my fanbase to be I talked a
lot of people in like I don't want my
fanbase to be just this I don't but if
it's a majority
Brown people doesn't bother me at all I
understand why that would be so do you
see a big representation in India yeah
fun fact
my top five countries one of them is
India but across the world my
demographic is females aged 13 to 25 the
only country where that's not true is
India and which it's older men watch my
videos really yes factual factual proof
what you think's going on there I think
all the perverted uncles in India are
like woo and they're just Pervin on me I
think next month when I go to India
they're all gonna be there permanent
well you know okay this is a you know
you're the psychology major so you tell
me but it seems interesting that you
know I'm following you know you know
better than we do but I read the news
and I see some of the things that are
happening in the end there's still just
rampant oppression of women and to think
that maybe the dudes who are upholding
that culture are privately reveling in a
girl who is totally rebelling against
everything they stand for how does that
make you know that's a lot of deep
thought I think that anyone that does
those acts of stupidity that you
mentioned isn't that deep to think that
far to be honest I think it's important
to mention that just on that nobody
touched on it is that India does get a
lot of that kind of media that's like oh
look we're so behind the times but
almost every country is like that and I
feel like before all my fans like oh
she's just hating on India that's an
important thing to remember is that okay
you're saying it's not representative
it's not representative of and you've
cause we see so many stories like that
but it happens in every country
unfortunately I feel like there are a
lot of issues in India that is
definitely one of them I feel like I get
most of my love and hate from India I'll
just say that most my love and hate is
from India I get a lot of that sexist
stuff that's like if you ever came to
India like we would disown you you're
just an absolute disgrace embarrassment
to Punjabi people but then I get like a
whole bunch of fangirls they're like yes
come to India I'm gonna freakin wear my
hat backwards just like you right so
it's a mix and so I mean you're going
back
mhm and I mean do you have plans to meet
up with fans a percent it's actually a
YouTube FanFest I'm going for so it's a
whole orchestrated meet-and-greet
performance type thing I'm actually
really curious to see how my fans in
India differ because I've been to
Australia New Zealand all over North
America and I'm just so curious to see
what their feedback would be because
they're probably gonna be the biggest
critics to be to be honest and the
biggest lovers at the same time so I've
never gone to any country and
experienced in-person hate before and I
don't know if I will in India but I kind
of almost want to see what it would be
like to be honest I want to see if
there's gonna be an enraged like uncle
that's like know my daughter spoke and
it's because of you like I really cared
you're gonna have security with you
under present did you not hear my
demographic facts a hundred percent I
would have security with me but I feel
like it's gonna be interesting I love
India I love it I don't love everything
that happens in it but as the place to
go I love it so I don't want to go you
should go yeah we can be your bodyguard
prep your bum hole Wow because of the
food yeah anything else yeah I mean I at
least look intimidating now neither one
of us could actually could actually do
any harm to anybody but I throw my brow
I can assimilate I'm gonna have to side
with with the tall man over here because
he looks like he could throw on you and
me both of the same time even when I
firm eyebrows yeah even even when you do
the epic rap battle of manliness I feel
like wow yeah that was me and my most
manliness yeah at that point puberty
went through him didn't you hear him no
that was me was that you really I can't
remember who raps why God so your fan
base has I mean it is certainly shifted
I would I would think here at least it's
you know you've got you've got this
community that is the the core your fan
base but you I mean you're you're you're
observing that you're reaching out more
right yeah I feel like that has happened
more in the last year where I go to meet
and greets and I see white people that
I'm like oh my god freaking amazing I'm
not gonna lie that feels pretty good and
not that I don't not down with my brown
homies but it feels good to know like oh
my content is actually spreading to more
people and I've noticed that more and
more and more
that more multiculturalism is happening
out meet and greets and performances and
it's awesome and I think that's because
when I first started making videos it
was very Indian mom brown mom Brown this
brown that I have some of those videos
sometimes but now it's like girls on
their period not brown girls on their
periods right it's I've just made my
content more global because I want it to
be received globally I don't want to
make content just for a specific group
of people well I think it's consistent I
mean even with some of the what you're
standing for and some of the things that
you're doing are to tear down some of
those barriers so so it makes sense that
okay guys I know we kind of built this
thing together but this is for everybody
I mean one of the things that you say is
this peace and strength without fear
without hate one love how does that
manifest itself in your in your videos
that is honestly something that I came
to believe through YouTube I've honestly
think my youtube journey has made me the
person I am spiritually so the tattoos I
have and say without fear without hate
because of my youtube journey um the one
love thing because of my youtube journey
I just when you read all the comments
and you see the world come together on a
website and on a web page you're like
holy crap there's so many people in the
world and they believe so many things
and there's so many things going on I
just want to bring people together show
them that were different but the same
like I mentioned earlier so what I mean
can you give us a couple of points of
how that happened I mean I know that I
read that something about the fight you
were having a bout with depression right
when you started your YouTube channel so
even if you could tell us about that and
then where you were spiritually at that
point as well what was the depression
when I went through depression was
actually before I started making YouTube
videos
um just depression of you know I fell
out with a few friends in school I
really do know what I want to do I hated
my last two years of university
absolutely not because I wasn't good at
school I just hated school I didn't want
to be there um so I had a lot of trust
issues growing up a lot of trust issues
with friends fell into depression but a
year had a really hard time getting out
of it and I was a gradual thing a lot of
factors it wasn't yeah like one
catastrophic event just life weighing
down on you in general and I remember
being on vacation with my
family in Dominican Republic and just
sitting literally on the beach alone and
I was like you know what I think I'd
like one or two videos out and I was
like I feel like I want to do this
YouTube thing full-time and one of my
really big deciding factors was I don't
know what it was I can't even remember I
remember one morning I woke up in the
middle of Oran towards end of my
depression I woke up and I just felt
good I don't know what it was like it
was random I hadn't felt good or happy
and so long and one morning I woke up
and I was like I feel better today and I
don't know why something switched in my
brain it might have been like a movie I
watched or something that happened and
so one of my deciding factors was holy
crap what if one of my videos could be
that thing that switches something in
someone else's brain and because of one
of my videos they're like I feel better
today for some random reason so that was
a really big deciding factor and that's
why all my videos have that underlying
happiness motivation because I want to
be that switch for people and I am that
switch for a lot of people which makes
it awesome because I do get a lot of
emails that are like your videos have
changed my view on this or that so the
depression played a huge role and the
direction of my videos in terms of the
how I became the spiritual more one love
I actually and you you guys are lucky
because I never talked about the sly sly
ones you are I made a video where I
talked about alcohol and I had my
character religiously dressed up so he
was wearing a turban and that was he was
drinking and there was a huge backlash
from the Sikh community that would like
you cannot portray Sikh people like this
I still to this day disagree with that
because I believe there's many people
who wear turbans that drink and they
should also be represented whether or
not you agree with that there's still
people and they exist whether or not you
want to pretend they don't is your
choice but they definitely do and so I
saw nothing wrong with that I was told
to take it down I didn't take it down
you were told by your commenters I was
told by an organization actually based
within Toronto a Sikh organization who
I'm actually friends with a lot of them
so it's nothing personal well and by
commenters as well who are like no you
should take this down and one of the
greatest lessons I learned is that well
let me ask what were you making a point
of a putt that it was hypocrite
oh not at all it had nothing to do with
religion the video it was simply the
fact that that character was wearing a
turban and was shown drinking so but
religion wasn't mentioned at all it was
implied by his headdress and so I
discovered then and I regret it so much
I made this whole video after explaining
my point of view on it and I regret that
so much today because when I look back
at that video I realized that out of the
10,000 comments it's maybe 10 that were
like oh you shouldn't do this but those
the 10 that stuck out to me at the time
that's the way it works right it works
that that's the way it works when you're
starting out so I'm his whole video I
also deleted that video explaining my
situation cuz I learned through this
process that I don't actually have to
explain it because I believe in that's
good enough but that really opened my
eyes to that I'm actually not a
religious person I'm a spiritual person
and I think that's what I was really
confused about growing up is that I
don't believe in religious rituals I
don't believe in following rules I
believe in spirituality I just believe
in being a good person I believe in one
God I believe in just honesty and those
general values and those are the ones I
will portray in my videos not any
religious ones so I think the greatest
thing that ever happened to me through
YouTube is learning that I'm spiritual
not religious because it's transformed
me and it's just overall happy put
together person now still being in
Toronto and still being probably around
some of those people that you got to
know through your your religion how have
they responded to this transformation
and what would you hear them saying
after to you after you just said that
well that whole group of people I'm like
I said I'm friends with a lot of them I
see them at a lot of events and I
sometimes a bit too much of a unicorn
where I'm like if you believe whatever
you want to believe and I support you
because I support people who believe in
something like just stand for something
whatever you stand for more power to you
man just believe in something so I see
them all the time a few of them probably
definitely hate me and that opened my
eyes even further because I think some
of the biggest people who have given me
a hard time because of religion are the
people who tweet about telling me I
should kill myself so that just kind of
shows how valid your opinion is when
you're telling me that you're a disgrace
to our religion because you support this
you should go kill yourself and you
should
I'll be someone another lycée about you
and your religious beliefs especially
when I look at your activities and
you're way worse than you ever preached
to be so I've just learned that I just
feel like a lot of religion has
hypocrisy based in it so right yeah I
find it also inspiring that you know
coming out of a place of depression
through YouTube I mean one would think
that opening up yourself to the scrutiny
of anyone's comments
it's just fertile ground to begin
depression right but you seem to have
found strength in them in the midst of
opening yourself up to this scrutiny hmm
it's weird how that works because anyone
who's starting no YouTube knows when you
first see those comments they burn those
first 10 videos those comments burn and
I don't know what it is like you know
since young I've always had that strong
will when I want to do something I will
do it no matter what and sometimes
really super annoying because I'm always
stressed about stupid crap but don't be
stressed about but a lot of those
comments did bother me but I feel like
right from the get-go I've been so
blessed that a lot of my stuff has been
received surprisingly positively there's
a lot of people have come up to me and
said when you go to meet and greets I
don't you ever have people say nasty
things you and I'm like never I've never
ever in my whole career had someone come
up to me in person and say anything
terrible to me which is a huge blessing
because I know that that's the opposite
for a lot of youtubers so do you see
yourself as a comedian or do you see
yourself as a spokesman I hate saying
the word comedian one because I really
don't think I'm funny and I swear that's
the truth two is because I don't like
categorizing myself into committing I
would say entertainer but then I always
say platform on YouTube because when I
say entertainer people think I'm a
stripper so I always have to clarify I
say entertainer because I like to do
comedy I love to act I love to rap I
love to host I love to just entertain in
general but do you also feel kind of the
weight of people's expectations in terms
of I mean the people that you're
inspiring being a spokesperson in that
capacity of I don't know either
representing a community or representing
a certain type of person that you want
to inspire right I got over the
whole situation and debate when I
decided I'm not gonna be religious
anymore and I've applied what I've
learned from that to everything else I
had this rule and I had to literally sit
down and talk to myself to discover this
rule it was don't ever go out of your
way to try to seem like a role model be
yourself and if people want you to be
their role model that's their choice a
good example of this is I will never lie
and be like oh no I don't drink at all
because I know it's frowned upon with
among South Asian females a lot of
people solvation be motioned drink even
though their fathers are usually always
drunk but um it's frowned upon I will
never lie be like no I don't then you
shouldn't and it's bad no because I do
drink from time to time but am I gonna
post an Instagram video of me being
drunk no that's the rule at Hogwarts
like because I wouldn't do that anyways
I'm not gonna promote it I'm not gonna
lie about it so what do you think is
because there are people who would post
a picture of themselves being drunk so
cool it is that where is that coming
from where do you think that that
internal standard is I think that's
coming from me just wanting to be myself
and me not wanting to do anything I do
for anyone else because that's one of
the reasons I got depressed not living
for myself I want to do everything I do
for myself I'm having me in the center
and if I want to do something and I
believe in it I'm gonna do it and a key
example is that whole religious thing
that happened I could have taken that
video down could've could've totally
caved but I didn't cuz I'm like I
believe in this and that's what I'm
gonna do what are some of the you know
because you've got such a an interesting
story and there is so much you know all
the stuff that we've been talking about
all the emotions what kind of
opportunities has that led to outside of
YouTube I it seems like you just be
getting contacted by all kinds of people
opportunities it gets unbelievable
I never thought I would do stand-up
until I got an email saying hey you
understand up and it's the most
intimidating thing you've ever done but
I've done stand-up I did a movie last
year which I did my first small role in
a future film I got to meet Kunal Nayyar
who's Raj and Big Bang Theory who I
become friends with him like what how
does this make any sense like I watch
you on TV so I got to do that I got to
be a wrap feature on an Indian artists
track who I listened to growing up I was
a huge fan of and again I was like
how did this happen I've met so many
cool people I got an ice-cream date with
m.i.a
she could she DM to me I was like what
is going on in my life Paris Jackson
Michael Jackson's daughter and I talk
because she's a fan of my videos like
what is my life like what is my life I
got understand so many opportunities
what kind of ice cream did you give yeah
you know I bought her some macaroons and
I got chocolate chip cookie dough ice
cream and she's just the most awesome
person to ever I think the greatest
thing YouTube has ever done is two
things
take me to awesome places like New
Zealand Australia these pieces I would
never ever go if it wasn't for this
journey and meeting awesome people I
think Michael Jackson's daughter
yeah I'm not met but we've had a
thorough conversation on Twitter well
yeah 140 characters at a time 140 kick
butt multiple times multiple hundred
four I think she even threw an emoticon
smiley face in there one time - so what
about you know definitely like those
sort of celebrity perk type things but
what about people expecting you to I
want you to show up and speak about this
issue at this place like some of those
weightier responsibilities that once you
kind of establish yourself as a voice
you know when you when you have your
background it just seems like people
would be like oh we need to get her to
come in and speak here or do or do this
100% I feel the first thing people will
look at when you are a youtuber of this
nature is not what you do so much it's
how many people you do it towards so a
lot people must be like hey so blatantly
my musics not doing so well you have two
million subscribers let's do a collab
track and I'm just like do we because
look at my content first and foremost
but having said that do get a lot of
emails that are like speak at this
convention speak about depression speak
about Sikhism speak about people getting
killed in this part of the world and
again my same rules if I believe in it I
will do it I am NOT a spokesperson
though I'm an entertainer if I speak
about certain issues while entertaining
that's fine but I do not want to be a
spokesperson because my job is to make
people laugh and smile and I feel in my
in my own way that is my social service
being that switch for people who are
upset who are sad because a lot of
people times people forget when they
email me but in this country people are
starving in this country people
I totally get that in my personal life
you know I sponsor a child I don't as
much as I can not things I need to
constantly advertise but as an
entertainer I feel wrong picking certain
issues that ignoring other ones so my
view is - I'm gonna promote one love
healthy living loving yourself because
those are just as important and it's all
the other issues and maybe that's
because I have a personal connection
with that which is probably true if
you're a youtuber who grew up in poverty
you're gonna make youtube videos
probably that address poverty when your
youtuber that grew up dealing with
racism you're probably gonna address
that a bit more right having said that
all those people that gave me backlash
because of my religious video I probably
people that grew up battling those
religious issues me I battled depression
so my videos are about happiness and
love and I think that's fair and as an
entertainer where are you gonna take
this um and you want everywhere
preferably not homelessness on the
unemployment line um honestly I'd love
to act I really really enjoy being on
set and I'd love to rap more not because
I'm super good at it because it makes me
feel the best out of everything I do
right cuz you're saying right right now
you you you specifically said YouTube is
not my career Entertainment is my career
on YouTube is a platform right for that
so are you like okay well if I could
suddenly be a movie star I'm I'm out of
here no because you know and this is
heavily inspired by Harley I'll never
forget when he told me this is like I
think people who get bigger deals and
start making YouTube videos are stupid
because you have a huge fan base there
that's where you started and you should
try to remain connected with that and
that really resonated with me of course
my whole life I might not be able to
make two videos a week but I really hold
a strong value should never just be like
not making youtube anymore anymore
because I'm a movie star I want to be
hopefully a movie star that's like hey
guys I'm making a video this month check
me out on YouTube I would not want to
neglect those fans who got me to the
place I'm at right yeah do you have a
sense of growing pressure with such a
accelerating fanbase and the numbers
getting to where they are and the
millions and millions is there is there
a pressure in what to keep delivering oh
yeah 100%
I feel like if I don't release a video
on Monday and there
people will be outside my house ready to
kill me there's definitely a pressure um
I feel like it's almost scary and I was
talking to this app I remember who maybe
Davey I was talking to him saying I feel
scared that I might get to a point where
it doesn't matter what I release people
will like it and a lot of people might
get confused by that saying isn't that
awesome you can put on anything and
we'll get like a million views like no
because I don't want my art form to get
to that point I want to make sure I have
to feel like no I need to impress with
this video and do awesome with this
video and so I felt I put that pressure
on myself where it's like I can make it
in just another Brown parents video and
it'll probably hit a million views but I
don't want to make just another Brown
parents video that's gonna hit a million
views so the challenge is figuring out
how to expand ya yourself for yourself
exactly hundred percent what you have an
answer I mean what it's constantly just
trying new things experimenting um what
I'm doing in LA actually is
collaborating something I've not done at
all really in my career thus far except
with a few people I'm not really in my
element when I collaborate so I
literally thrust myself into an
uncomfortable situation collaborated
with a whole bunch of people who I
secretly fangirled meeting so that was
difficult as well and that's just one
way where I'm like I'm going to up my
content and collaborate with people that
people would never think I would do it
with and I I get the impression based on
when you were having communications with
Stevi about coming in here that you're
up at all hours of the night yes
what are you doing texting you know what
body at 3:00 a.m.
always you know what it is I have this
theory that if you don't if you don't
lie down at 9:00 you're absolutely
exhausted then you're not doing
something right so I need to be
absolutely exhausted when I go to sleep
I have a really big issue with being
lazy I feel really guilty doing it I
feel really guilty you're nothing you're
not what you're working you're not what
I'm working at party even when I oh god
no I don't I first of all partying is
hiring like like I get tired partying I
think I was talking my friend the other
day was like 10 o'clock at my house and
people are over and I was like oh my god
I want to like just lie down cuz I get
tired partying I like to work I don't
like when when you send Stevie the text
and you're still up it from working I'll
get
from partying yes well I would say that
you know I appreciate the sentiment I'll
always want to go to bed extremely tired
yes as I'm not your doctor but I will
just say on behalf of the medical
community
you should get eight hours of sleep
having said that though you'll never
receive a text from me at 9:00 a.m. or
10:00 a.m. because you'll be asleep
obviously okay so only 3:00 a.m. and
5:00 a.m. shift did I just [ __ ] I just
do a lot of you know the excuse
creatives use that like no I'm just more
creative at 9:00 I do it's just because
we're effed up and we do stuff at night
so you're nocturnal yeah so I just have
a little bit of a shift o'clock okay I
get it so when you all told me to come
in here at 11:00 I listening to I think
it was the black sheep
growing up rap group any we're making
this reference right now but he was
bragging about going to sleep in the
early morning and waking up at noon and
I was like so that's the schedule of a
rapper I want to be a rapper you know
how about this you know single you're
single right single attractive so how
has this affected your love life thanks
for saying I have a love life that's
really sweet of you
um honestly my love life is interesting
in the sense that it is literally
whatever people want to be I could right
now right here be like I have a
boyfriend this is his name and then I
can post an Instagram picture with you
and you will then be my boyfriend okay
I've also pictures my cousins with a
caption saying my cousin and then people
have been like oh it's her boyfriend so
I feel like when you're in the public
eye what you say doesn't matter like
does what Rihanna and Chris Brown say
matter at all to what we think not at
all we'll think whatever the hell we
want to think and we'll run with it so
but we really want to know I really want
to know I will say that is affected my
love life in the sense that people see
this strong intimidating female and guys
are scared of me I'll say that Wow guys
are scary to me like literally running
from you um I think guys especially and
this is me calling out all brown guys
are a little bit intimidated by a South
Asian theme Oh who's outspoken and who's
also sometimes my confidence I'm a very
confident person sometimes too confident
and I think that deters a lot
guys away from me do you think if you
had to make a prediction would you think
you'll end up with a brown guy I think I
will end up with a guy I really don't
care if he's brown to be honest that
doesn't bother me at all I feel like if
I did end up with a brown guy I would
like it because we probably have more in
common than someone else and especially
then my mom wouldn't go through
depression but but I feel like he would
really have to be a brown guy that gets
out of that idea that's South Asian
females should be quiet like I would
never if he's like cultured like that
then he'll know that's not happening
right yeah so there's no candidates
right now well I don't know you two a
pretty good-looking like we're taking it
was theirs married there's no there's
those people that I constantly couple
not just rose I said that in a totally
defeated way happily married good
good I'll stop hitting on you then so
are you wives mr. and mrs. rhett and
Link I said Mr by the way I made one of
you mr. mrs. Rhett laughs well it's in
that if you put it in the right order
I'll tell you that much this for a
second if you had to pair me up with
someone what would you describe the guys
put you on the spot for a second Wow
this is what what what are the
characteristics okay if I was playing
that white bodybuilder what perfect love
it if I was playing matchmaker for you
which I don't play matchmaker with
anybody I mean so this is it's not a
good idea this is not a good idea that
was a black sheep lyric one time I write
I would say that well my prediction
would be that you would end up with
someone who comes from a similar
background but has experienced the same
revolution in their life Wow
I like that because it just seems like
there's that revolution well you've
stated it pretty well okay good so I'd
like you know your little best answer
I've ever received this question maybe
that's but but then he
is half let's make him half something
like half Oh golly in half imagine I'm
done with we can't breathe him I mean if
that we can screw it would be a baby now
so we're not I mean and that would be a
highly ethically questionable if we
started at daytime in it involved I'm
okay or breeding I'm okay with that I
mean if you get two different
ethnicities in one that's pretty that's
this that's a sore who's really one
ethnicity Lincoln I can really tell you
Athens I don't care about it at all like
at all I know my parents hate that I
don't care what at all I don't care what
ethnicity the guys I don't care well
we're not of much help at this point I
think I really like your whole I really
liked your answer of experience the same
revolution it's very important what
about my answer kind of shallow and yeah
yeah what okay that was good - but you
do anticipate some difficulties with
your parents and you also you
specifically call out your mom again
when you think that no I just say mom
weren't because like she's my homey okay
my dad how do you think that's gonna go
over I think my parents have come to a
point in life now especially because of
my career choices everything I've done
is so unconventional where they've kind
of given up but not in a totally
terrible way what if I come home they're
gonna know we're gonna tell Lily not to
do this she's probably still gonna do it
so let's just start freaking accepting
it right off the bat that's what it's
gonna be literally they know that
because they did everything to stop me
from dancing I still ended up dancing
they did everything to convince you not
to YouTube I'm a youtuber I think
they've accepted that lily is that
daughter that's gonna do what she wants
to do right which sucks because my
sister is the opposite of that
but I've already accepted that she's the
star child so it's like you've buttered
them up a little bit little bit all the
choices that you've made yeah
bringing home you know a half and a half
guy you know what I feel like the
greatest thing about this is that I've
proven to my parents that I made the
right choice because they're so proud of
the YouTube thing now right and I think
the other kind of trust my judgment so I
could bring home a house barge and I'll
be fine seek and a half's part well it's
been a pleasure getting to know you and
hear your story so much it's time
to sign the table oh my god I'm signing
the freaking table and that's our
conversation with superwoman the
conversation has landed but superwoman
has flown away she's no longer here I
learned a couple of things I learned her
neck her necks you learned I learned the
Kinect Wow and I was about to tell you
something about pronunciation and I came
up with a word called cred necked okay I
learned the correct pronunciation of
sikhism and the incorrect pronunciation
of correct okay but I also learned that
I should potentially start a matchmaking
service dad just because my advice
sucked doesn't mean your advice is great
I mean she was impressed but basically
all you did was you said in a very
eloquent way you're you're gonna you're
gonna end up with someone who's had the
same journey as you it was I mean it was
profound though in her sounded profound
I mean did you see the look on her face
when I delivered that I felt like I'd
found my calling you know it's like I
need to be well maybe I should be a
fortune teller because I really just
told her her future it's really what I
did I did not match make her make her a
match you know like a little ribbon I
don't believe in fortune telling I can't
well of course but it's all it's all a
scam anyway to make money you know if
this doesn't work out well I can't
support you than that if you want to
start a dating site like Rhett helps
mingle calm or whatever you want to call
it I don't know Rhett helps you mingle
that's not bad
more power to you emphasis on you with
no emphasis on the US but you're saying
you I don't want you to be a fortune
teller with me that would be weird to
walk into like a fortune telling duo
you know you definitely immediately seem
outnumbered you feel like you're the
victim of something oh no no I'll do the
fortune teller thing with you but you'll
have an earpiece and I'll be in the
other room googling whoever you're
talking to and feeding you miraculous
information about good I like that and
say just rephrase something about their
own life in terms of that's who they're
going to want
be with in the future and I don't
impress him if we're gonna do this we
probably shouldn't let people hear this
this plan because well we're not can't
take advantage of anybody oh you're
still listening out there and you're
biscuit land okay thank you for doing
that I didn't know you would hang on
this long but we will be here next week
to give you another one of these where
you can learn how to pronounce or not
pronounce things or whatever you know we
value the time that you have spent with
us in the meantime this week you will
have good experiences you have bad
experiences you'll probably eat
something and sleep you don't they'll
also still sleep a little bit but you
should sleep more the help that was your
larger fortune I was predicting your
future for the week
[Music]
[Music]